new information shows how police used
genealogy websites to try to identify
the notorious Golden State killer police
arrested Joseph James D'Angelo on
Tuesday after crime scene DNA partially
matched a relative's on one of those
sites D'Angelo is accused in a
decades-old crime spree across 10
California counties John Blackstone is
at the jail in Sacramento where the 72
year old will be arraigned this
afternoon John good morning good morning
well Joseph D'Angelo will face a judge
here today at the Sacramento County Jail
the alleged Golden State killer was
careful not to leave behind any
incriminating clues he couldn't have
possibly known he'd be unmasked by his
own DNA more than 40 years later the
Golden State killer wore a ski mask and
left no fingerprints while committing
more than 50 rapes and a dozen murders
but he did leave behind his genetic code
the final piece of the puzzle for
Sacramento County District Attorney Ann
Marie Schubert and her investigators I
believe very strongly that it's the
greatest tool ever given to law
enforcement agents extracted the
suspects genetic profile from
decades-old crime scene evidence and
then searched genealogy websites for
matches they got a partial hit from
someone related to Joseph James D'Angelo
on Jed match.com police say another DNA
test confirmed the 72 year old ex police
officer was the Golden State killer it
was hugely excited
Ruth Ballard runs a forensic biology
program at California State University
Sacramento I didn't really think they
were gonna solve this case quite frankly
D'Angelo's brother-in-law is in
disbelief I would have never suspected
we you know we had a family-size
relationship so we joked to me you know
we hunted boudin he favors quiet upper
class suburbs usually works in the
pre-dawn hours and often spends several
hours in the home the Golden State
killer snuck through windows and
surprised his victims even eating food
from their refrigerators while they were
tied up the crimes pretty lasted from
1974 to 1986 around the mid 80s that was
when the first cases
we're being solved using DNA and so it
was on the radar I think of criminals
that were savvy that may have been the
reason this stopped mysteriously in the
middie it's possible CBS this morning
contacted other genealogy websites to
see if they provided any help to
investigators ancestry.com 23andme Jen
Cove and DNA land all denied being
involved Nora all right John thank you
this story is so chilling to me that
it's a police officer because the police
officer could have such access to
information about this case and who
would look at a police officer for
something like this
I like the idea for somebody who is as
gruesome as this if this is true yeah
you can't hide no matter how long ago it
was no not his DNA but a DNA of a
relative that led to him yeah it's
amazing this is amazing